my biggest complaint about you over the
course of our marriage and this is not
recent because it definitely changed and
I I don't know if I changed or if you
changed or if it was some combination of
change
but you used to snore no you used to be
insanely jealous oh yes
and that was a hard pill to swallow it
was really it's very hard being married
to somebody who is jealous yeah and like
you had jealousy of things that were not
like you had a perception of a scenario
like for example best example ever it
was our first week of marriage because
we didn't take our honeymoon and I was
working I was you were working and I
went to visit you in Boston and we went
to this Italian restaurant and the
waiter was like a very cute old man he's
definitely in his 70s if not 80s right
and I remember this he said to me uh he
leaned down and he said and and for the
principessa do you remember yeah I got
upset and I thought it was so cute that
this little old man called me a princess
yeah and and I looked at him and I gave
him my order in a very Smiley way and he
walked away and you
picked a horrible fight I remember that
I remember that look at age 25
um
I was pretty insane
um but that jealousy thing definitely
followed me for a while I'm not jealous
anymore I'm so grateful that you're not
because it really is like it was the one
thing that I I don't pray for things or
people or stuff like that I just sort of
like pray that in general things oh
please God don't let him be jealous I
would just be like please let him lose
this
personality flow it's a flaw of
character I agree with you it's a
character flaw it's ugly and it's ugly
as it feels to the person who has to be
on the receiving end of it it's such an
ugly feeling inside because I just if
this is any consolation you know you're
being crazy
the jealous person knows that this is
wrong and it's
it's ugly but they can't help it and so
what changed is the question I don't
know I think you know I wanted to do
some work on myself and
um that was one of the major things that
I needed to work on because it was it
was getting in the way
[Music]